regardez-nous à nouveau Réunion on
voulait seulement vous offrir une vraie
lune de miel je viens de trouver cette
petite chose qui remplace sous ma table
d'où vous nous emmener dans un endroit
aussi splendide que ça quand
tu leur a rien dit ils seront partis
depuis longtemps quand je commencerai
mon truc de boulot vous devez être
monsieur Parker nos classes d'excuses
pour ce changement de date monsieur yon
vous propose un verre en tant qu'invité
écoutez c'est un contrat super important
tout le monde se tient à Caro
ah
bon
[Musique]
je t'ai trouvé le meilleur cadeau de
mariage quoi pourquoi cette coque n'a
pas le goût de coca
c'est pas comme ça que je voyais des
choses
depuis qu'il est là il a transformé ses
relaxants de vacances familiales en
totale chaos qui fait ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a traversé de l'enfer
[Musique]
du corps d'une personne j'ai beaucoup
vomi ton trou de balle qui a vomi
[Musique]